out of the 50 plus movies you've
directed and produced which was the
hardest to find financing for well I
would definitely say the first one if
anyone says no to you and you're
discouraged for one second you're dead I
think it's helpful to invest your own
money into whatever projects that you're
doing you know that's something that
I've always done and that I believe in
and I would never be a part of a project
that I wouldn't be willing to invest in
as well I but all the money I have most
of the time if the film doesn't do I
start from scratch again like I know
these filmmakers out of New York and
they make it fun where a couple of years
and they they made their they maybe went
on sixteen they they raised a lot of
money and then it went six super 16 a
few years ago then the next one for like
40 grand they wanted to make another one
they didn't have access to money and
that's generally teaming up with either
a production company or a network that's
a traditional why you going you picture
network HBO what-have-you and they're
gonna go into business with you that's
ideally the way you do things no we went
out and we actually raised quite a bit
of sponsorship money I'd say I want to
say around 50 grand and then there was
again private investment put into that
film probably equal amount and private
investment so we actually had a nice
chunk of money that was put in that film
because we got closer to release there
was another little bit of investment
that came in to finish it up because of
different reasons they weren't able to
finance it at the end so you know
sometimes production companies will have
a slate of three films that year and one
will go way over budget and another one
will get pushed and you know there's
just there's always different reasons
why financing can fall through when we
created the business plan we needed to
and projects that were successful to
compare them to ours and there weren't
any projects films that had a
predominantly Latino cast that were
successful they just aren't it was just
a long process of really getting a lot
of nose at one point I think I
calculated it was like it sorry once it
got like over like 150 nose or so I just
I stopped counting like I kept the
running chart and when it was like hit
that many of people like financed ears
or producers or companies production
companies they have passed on it then I
just like stopped keeping a number tally
because I got a little depressing I mean
my last one took four years to be able
to make and it's it's not an uncommon
story among wrong filmmakers I mean any
time anybody gives you money to make a
movie I mean you just thank your lucky
stars cuz it's a greatest job in the
world and it's such a commitment of
faith you know in in a filmmaker to be
like here you go here's a bunch of money
make it into a piece of art you know
huns like okay